it's not unusual in calculus textbooks
to see something uh to see problems
along the lines of prove
that the limit
as x approaches i don't know let's say
as x approaches 1
of let me think of an interesting
function when x approaches one let's say
three x
times x minus one
over
x minus one and you might say hey so why
did you do this x minus 1 in the
numerator and denominator well i did
that because obviously you can't have a
0 down here so this function is actually
not defined at x is equal to 1. right if
i just put a 3x this clear this cancels
out for all the other values so this is
essentially the line 3x except it has a
hole at x is equal to 1. that's why i
did it because i want to take the limit
and it's interesting to take a limit to
a point where the function doesn't exist
but the books will say hey prove that
this limit is equal to
well it would actually be equal to 3
right
prove that and you essentially have to
use the epsilon delta definition of a
limit so to prove this you're
essentially proving what this means and
this means
proving this is the same thing as
proving
so you could just prove
that given so if you know if you give me
some epsilon greater than zero and
remember that's how close you want f of
x to get to the limit given some epsilon
greater than zero in order for this to
be true i need to prove that i can give
you that there exists that you know i
can give you i can
give
a delta
greater than 0
where as long as
as long as
the distance between
x
and our limit point
x and 1
is less than delta
remember we don't want x to ever get
right on top of the limit point because
the function might not be defined there
so the distance between x and 1 has to
be greater than 0 right that's what this
tells us
so i have to prove
you give me an epsilon then i can give
you a delta and as long as x is within
delta of one and this is all they're
saying as long as the distance between x
and one right that's when you subtract
two things you take the absolute value
that's just distance so as long as the
distance between x and one is less than
delta
then
the distance between
3x let me write that up there the
distance between 3
x
times x minus 1
over x minus one that's the function
right
the distance that
and the limit point
and three is going to be less than the
epsilon
right in a lot of calculus textbooks you
know they'll
they'll write it generally like the
limit of f of x as x approaches
a of equals l and so this would be a
this would be your f of x and this would
be your l right there but anyway when
someone says they want you to prove this
they essentially want you to prove this
i'll give you an epsilon
you have to prove that any epsilon that
you're given that or that you give me
that i let's say i'm the one that has to
prove it any epsilon you give me i have
to be able to give you a delta where as
long as x is within delta of one
then the function is within epsilon
of the limit point
and how do we do that
and now you know i'll just say you know
a lot of proofs it's just kind of they
there's not a um
well there's not a systematic way to do
proofs and that's kind of what makes
them so interesting on a lot of levels
but these they're kind of tend to be a
systematic way and this you know this
problem i've given you to some degree is
kind of the easy one that they'll give
when they when they ask you to prove
these but they usually involve starting
from this point right here
and algebraically manipulating it until
you get until this expression right here
looks something like this expression
and then you'll have you know this
expression is less than you know epsilon
divided by something or you know some
function of epsilon it's like oh well as
long as delta is that you give me uh you
know an epsilon i can just apply that
you know take epsilon divided by four or
whatever and use that as my delta then
i've proved the theorem and so we'll do
that here so let's start with this
let's start with kind of where we want
to get to and then
and then figure out a delta that's
essentially a function of epsilon so
that whenever i whenever i'm given an
epsilon i can say hey whatever number
you give me i'm going to give you back a
number that's you know that divided by
whatever and then this will all work so
let's do that so
immediately we can simplify this we can
cross these out we you know you you and
when you cross that out you start to say
well we can't do that as long as x
they can only happen you can only do
this as long as you assume that x does
not equal one because at x equals one
this function is undefined right and
that's okay because we only care about
the intervals as x approaches one
we only care about the intervals as x
approaches one we don't care exactly
when x is equal to one so that's fine
so then this simplifies to
this right there simplifies to the
absolute value of three x
minus three
is less than epsilon
and then we could factor out a three so
that's you know you could say the
absolute value of three times x minus 1
is less than epsilon and you might
already see we already have an x1 minus
1 there and x minus 1 there if we can
get this 3
over on this side then we'll be done
essentially
so the absolute value of
3 times some other number it's going to
be the same thing as the as you know the
absolute value of three times the
absolute value of x
minus one
and if you don't believe me i mean try
it out with a bunch of numbers this is
going to be positive no matter what this
is going to be positive no matter what
it's going to have the same magnitude
right and of course that is less than
epsilon and so we say you know a lot of
times the calculus teacher will say if
this is true
this is true if and only if this is true
and that's just a fancy way of saying so
sometimes i'll do a two-way arrow
sometimes i'll write if and only if kind
of an if
an if with two f's but that just means
if that's true that's true and if this
is true then that's true and that's
generally the case whenever you just do
some algebraic manipulation you can
manipulate this back to get that or that
to get that and then they'll say well if
this is true this is true if and only if
this is true but this is just algebraic
manipulation right because you can go
back and forth between these steps and
that's true if and only if that is true
and then the absolute value of 3 is just
3 right we know that let's divide both
sides by 3 and you get
well i can just get rid of the absolute
value signs right there because we know
that's 3. if you divide both sides of
this equation by 3 you get the absolute
value of x minus 1 is less than epsilon
over 3. so what have we just done so far
we've just proved that
the absolute value
the absolutely write this in another
color we've just proved that the
absolute value of
essentially well three x times x minus
one over
x minus one
minus three
is less than epsilon
if and only if if
if and only if x minus 1 is less than
epsilon over 3
right so it's like this is true
this is true
as long as the distance between x and
one is less than epsilon over three
so we can just use epsilon over three as
our delta remember the whole point of
this was like you give me an epsilon
you give me a distance or you you say i
want to be within this distance of my
limit point i want the function to be
that close to the limit point and this
is just the distance between the
function
and the limit point right this is f of x
and this is the limit that it approaches
so you want to be that close and i say
well you're going to be that close if
and only if x the distance between x and
1 or the distance between x and the
value it's approaching is less than this
so we just prove this algebraically so
whatever number you give me if you give
me a if you say sal i want to be within
one of the limit point i want f of x to
be no further than one from the limit
point then i'll say okay then i'll give
you one third right as this is true
let me write that out
so let's say you pick one as a
as an epsilon so
you say hey you need to prove to me
that
there's some x value
where uh
as long as the the x value is no more uh
there's some value of delta so as long
as we're no more than delta away from
one then uh then the function itself
will be no more than one away from the
limit value right
and says i say well you gave me an
epsilon is equal to one
so i could just make i could just say
this is you know we just proved if and
only if
absolute value of x minus one is less
than whatever number you gave me divided
by 3. and that actually makes a lot of
sense if you graph this equation
let me see let me draw the
x-axis
y-axis we already established this thing
looks just like
the equation of 3x except it has a hole
at x is equal to 1.
so let me draw
the graph it'll have slope
i have a slope of 3 so it'll be pretty
steep it looks something like that
and when
when we're at one
this point right here there's a hole
right this is three
so all we're saying we just proved that
so this is so if you said that you
wanted to be within one of our limit
point that's like you giving me an
epsilon of
one so this distance right here
is one
right which would be a pretty big number
so you want the function to be within
one
of our limit point right because this is
the limit point
then all what we're saying is you just
have to take one third of that so we
just have to be within one third so this
distance right here
is one third
away from one or we could have said more
generally this if this is epsilon this
is epsilon this would be epsilon over
three this is epsilon over three and the
reason why this is a proof because it
shows no matter what epsilon you give me
i can always find a delta because i can
just take whatever number you gave me
and divide it by three and i can divide
any real number greater than zero i can
divide any real number by three so i can
always no matter what you give me i can
always find you something else and
therefore i have proven by the epsilon
delta definition of limits that the
limit as x approaches 1 of this is equal
to 3.